[Music]
how signal numerals
my name's welcome to notes there are two
the wrath of Milwaukee Malik whatta I
had two thousand FPS before I started
recording holy [ __ ]
alright let's play on medium I think
Nosferatu
means like vampire or something cuz when
I google - I saw some pretty creepy
vampire picture so that has to be no
weird is a longing screen I've ever seen
opium loads we'll see I guess
constructing random castle there's like
Minecraft but Castle craft vampire craft
I'm confused
hey working I think at me why would the
castle be random Megan or Sam's think is
working I hope it's like that's a demon
pentagram thingy loading its loading
again and someday I heard like loading
screen sir but a loading screen here I
[Music]
don't like this it's going on
right
uh-oh there's not good
it's bad the [ __ ] is creeped us out this
game is kind of all don't judge it for
the for his graphics I know a lot of
people like the graphics sucks but this
there's a huge
iced tea October night in the
Transylvanian mountain vampires will
arrive to join your family and their
closest friends at castle Malachi bacon
is to be Wed to the son of
[Music]
Count Dracula I know this deriving a
delay to the new family your 3rr the
reunion and I'm thrilled Maurice the
wolf phone have a boner that's why our
eldest as the coach taking the train
station hurries through the fog towards
the dark and ominous looking castle
uh-huh you get a horrible feeling that
everything is not I don't trust this
brave Oh No
he raped my family that's not good my
sister had real Abiquiu huge titties and
I good I mean it's good for him but not
for me cuz I do whatever all right
so we're here to kill Dracula mouth
drops you offered the castle gates you
left alone in the dark your torch
barely illuminating the large cloud the
dinar in front of you and I see Wilson's
a horrifying truth
bones I managed to push massive changes
Oh cat them and I'm strong prepare
yourself
bring it Lord break
oh no that's not good for anyone except
me probably me too good for you
all right you see the graphics are
amazing you have done an old stone laid
courtyard fronting a huge ancient castle
you must rescue your casa press tab hey
Rebecca hey I got big old Eddie's all
right we should save Rebecca first just
saying all right what is this hey it's
my suitcase and I have a Sunday my
suitcase how do i this is my best
did I just hurt Holly [ __ ] I'm hurting
her oh there's like a you seen the left
corner it is like a I have a son bring
it [ __ ]
Oh God okay all right this don't look at
that all right I am looking down geese
cry
I don't trust this place ha I don't know
harp what is this oh hey yeah alright
let's go here oh this is creepy
equip a wooden stake alternative fire
click the fall the right click what's
going on here can I take this like this
ok ok fast what are you doing you're not
supposed to be you sent him I knew it
alright I'll deal you with your barrels
in lane there you are flying how's it
possible
I don't trust flying barrels but this is
how are you doing this 3 hurry barrel it
makes no sense why are you flying
I hate barrel the [ __ ] was that Jesus
Christ this place smells and during my
new shoes I bought this yesterday they
were white now they are green and
[Music]
analysis all right
oh [ __ ] okay
you speak Japanese huh I speak Japanese
I invented the language all right [ __ ]
come here babe what are you a Dan chill
[ __ ] is she is that she spoke Japanese
[Music]
Thai police police you freaked the hell
out of me all right bye damn damn ba ba
ba yes this your man now barrels Jesus
Christ
hey Caramba all right let's look at for
Rebecca and her theories all right quest
continuous swing my [ __ ] saddle
nightlock [ __ ] bang
stop that's the other one what is the
other one and that was two I swear that
was two
huh tell us this Jesus Christ I'd like
her but I help her
I don't trust this place I'm not one bit
alright harp I don't like hot bigger if
it's only harp it's not good it's like
when you're possessed all right you
can't just help you have to help and are
otherwise bad things happen Jesus Christ
what is that thing
what is this place I just want to find
the Rebecca in there today's hello how
is it possible I need to find another
way I don't trust you barrels all right
let's continue back my house all right
I'm just gonna go back splice fix the
penis out of me they no longer feel like
I have one
what is this you need the West slinky
right let's go down here cut out I don't
trust this what now picked up the game I
don't trust any of you
nothing in it but what about I found a
medium health bag good I can use all the
help I don't like you very much
I'm sorry all right Japanese time you
speak it shut up
you speak some nice top top top top she
understood it
Oh No if you understood you would stay
down ha but this is Christ Japanese half
stop
chop-chop yes stay down
Jesus Christ freakin vampires and
werewolves what is this place why is it
nothing here why do they make me go to
these creepy places I'm just a man with
the Sun why my shoes are totally ruined
it's not worth it anymore I'm out of
here I don't care if she has big titties
all right let's check the other side
oh wait here's something to Jesus credit
all right I'm just gonna look at this
chest oh yes I think I just came
ammunition ah [ __ ] it's this nomination
I don't need ammo I need a [ __ ]
revolver all right okay I don't trust
this place we're gonna check this place
out but unfortunately in the next
episode like a favorite if you enjoyed
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see you tomorrow with new shoes
[Music]
holy [ __ ] a sword
I am Excalibur holy I want to penetrate
the bro with this mic wow this is
awesome